welcome one and all to another
installment of no meme left behind our
second installment of possibly the best
series to ever exist on YouTube that's
true that's true
today we look back on the memes that
were fallen in combat that were left
behind we have a huge master document of
tons of research that we've done over
the year and essentially there's so much
great content we don't have time to get
to over the course of these podcasts so
what we do is we look back through the
document we find our favorite segments
that were left behind and no memes are
left on here in the HD army so we grab
them we put them straddle them over our
shoulders and we take them to the
infirmary the firmer area to get them
all healed up because no goddamn meal of
mine these are worthy me these are some
of the best stuff we've got a great
terrific show here planned dan and Ian
are going to be joining us today
it's very excited to share with you guys
we are sponsored today by doordash endo
Chino and Dollar Shave Club did you play
Zach's intro music Dan we did was that
fire it was pretty freaking fire my dude
so that insane guitar solo was by the
one and only
yours truly Zach Zach you can show him
on the camera there Zach that's us
Christ's sake just click Zach please for
the love of God just click over to Zach
area Zach hi Zach is a shredder on
Instagram with your Instagram Zach Z
underscore vinyl there it is folks you
can see you see him there
ela has one week left from today
actually so this may well be our last
podcast and probably it probably likely
is yeah so from between now and next
Friday we're gonna have a baby I know
that's so fun it's so weird because
everything still feels like normal yeah
more you know more or less but just it's
like one day it's all it's like
once you break once that baby comes it's
on you no but between now and a week
it's going down we know yes and no yeah
I am ready I want to get my body back I
want to feel not pregnant mm-hmm but I'm
also not ready I think you're ready I'm
ready I think you're get you you you
always think yourself oh well your Mac
sighs you cannot gonna get any bigger
but in the past like week I would say
you has gotten I mean show him your
shirt how show him how that shirt fits
you yeah I was jacket you really let's
get a look at you I mean here give him a
profile shot somehow it doesn't do it
justice though to give him profile it
doesn't do you judge it doesn't really
capture the insanity of it aren't you
supposed to look fatter on camera wasn't
wasn't that like a man yeah people said
but I feel like it's tough is it yeah
it's a myth you look better on camera
people look better my skin looks good on
camera I don't know why I don't even
wear I don't wear makeup
I feel like videos have gotten so good
you can't wear makeup on video anymore
because you just look like you're a dude
wearing makeup and it looks Vic Ulis you
know you watch like old TV shows in 4k
and you can tell I don't know how they
restore how do they convert old shitty
footage to 4k maybe you know the answer
to that one of you guys back there Dan
uh if they have the original masters
like film masters it's pretty easy but
if it was shot on video like if it was a
show that was originally on video it's
kind of a [ __ ] process they're just
like up scaling everything shot
originally that original footage is like
you can bump that up to 4k the
informations they're not okay that's
what Dan saying oh if it's on film yeah
yeah if you still have the original film
masters because it's a photograph yeah
yeah I mean film is actually higher than
4k oh wow so you can see all these bozos
walking around with tons of makeup on
their face and you see how shitty the
details of everything is kind of
interesting like people
we're complaining about this dark Game
of Thrones episode in ela I think had a
really good theory about that is that
often times when you see an video things
are super blurry or shaky or dark
they're trying to hide details yep
yeah I think so it probably just doesn't
look that good so that's why there's no
light it's because they're hiding the
details yeah although you have to
consider was if it's not seeing anything
better than saying shitty I don't know I
guess they decided it was regardless I
am very excited to get started today but
before we do I have some topical things
that are fresh memes that I've have not
fallen income by the way is drama season
over yeah it's over that's what we're
doing though drinking coffee again right
and I went to dr. coffee he's right out
I like threw my webkinz out it was a
good run though wasn't it it was like a
really good run man for real I was
getting I was becoming like an anxious
person there was just so much drama in
the air every day like projared
James Charles jeffree star faze clan it
was like boom boom boom what's next baby
it's beautiful mmm and then when it was
over I opened Twitter and it was just
like Trump okay close Trump Trump said
that the Holocaust didn't happen out
back to the back to the normal news
Trump there's a great Trump news now I
don't like talking about politics but
this one is pretty good how he covered
he had the Schuyler's cover the there's
a battleship called the John McCain and
he had the sailors cover it with a tarp
because he was where was it in Japan he
was visiting Japan to be fair I think
the story isn't that he did it it's that
his staffers are so afraid of triggering
him that they did it for him I don't
think he came from the White House
though I don't know I mean I have a hard
time believing that his staff would just
preemptively be like we got a
cover the Germany when they imagine
working I mean what the hell you got you
already made the battleship in honor of
this man and his family his legacy his
grandfather apparently was a Admiral
that it's named after and you get a cup
you're gonna cover these great Americans
with a [ __ ] tarp because this man's
too sensitive is these name I mean how
bright this is this is new levels of
insanity you know thank you
we haven't yet introduced that meme so
yeah brushed it's fallen but it's fresh
so anyway I don't wanna get into all
that but you know oh there's another
thing of Donald Trump I really I don't
want to go down this rabbit hole this is
just funny stuff I'm not talking
politics but Trump Trump pants was so
good
where was that it was like Memorial Day
Trump or what was the recent holiday you
guys yeah Memorial are you talking about
his pan how covered his whole shoe
picture I miss it yeah I think this is
it but it's super low quality but his
pants covers this whole fricking shoes
and you're the freakin president you
have like a tailor in the damn White
House probably covers his actual entire
show
it's wild man it's almost like when you
see crazy designer stuff right that
could be on the runway oh definitely not
high fashion
his wife was a model so maybe she's you
know pushing in that direction a little
vitamins man that's awesome yeah Betty
ms.fer definitely charged three thousand
dollars for this damn cool all right
enough Trump business what's ready he
just screamed yeah he's okay oh he's
just trying to get him you're such a
drama queen
so our favorite preacher we talked about
this guy previously he bought
a airplane for himself a jet it's like
I'm not just a airplane it's like a
luxury the private jet stream yeah it's
like a 60 million dollar jet he called
he says I don't fly coach because it's a
tube full of demons you refer to coach
people as the little demons in a tube so
that's why he needed a luxury I'm with
him on that oh boy so he was recently
ambushed by Inside Edition they caught
him out and his Escalade outside what
looks like his winger his plane I don't
know what the hell it is but here they
go they get him good and it's it's it's
a fascinating look how are you sir we
just like to ask you about why you don't
want to fly commercial
why have you said that you won't fly
commercial you said that it's like
getting into a tube with a bunch of
demons listen to me just sing not the
people and this creeps me out his eyes
in his gaze cause he's got like a
demonic gaze right I don't have to stop
65% of what I'm doing you think it hears
mouths why is your mouth how much money
did you pay for Tyler Perry's Gulfstream
jet for example well for example that's
really none of your business but the
business of your donors this is so sharp
I paid so kind of caught me off guard
here oh so it's a long vid so I've
time-stamped some of my favorite moments
for your enjoyment but there's something
so unsettling about this man's demeanor
and face and and he started creep creep
here he responds to again getting to uh
calling coach passengers demons back to
the comment you said that you don't like
to fly commercial because you don't want
to get into a tube with a bunch of
demons do you really believe that human
beings are demons Oh
do not and don't you ever say I did well
or what we wrestle not wise I don't like
people that go from wrath to smiling
that quick are not angelic no evoke a
movie only in a movie I've seen it he's
literally a villain he's literally a
Batman villain he looks like Charles
Manson there you have it we wrestled not
he does this throughout the video he
just got this whole thing I don't know
why people buy but he goes he does what
this has said we wrestle not with demons
we wrestle not with other dudes that are
that's gay he's anti-gay missa
politician powers can you explain what
you mirror and don't you ever say I did
his eyes are sore not with flesh and
blood but principalities and powers
sorry can you explain what you got a
response just
just explain because it's really simple
you said we didn't want to get into a
tube with a bunch of demons what did you
mean well let me ask you do you think
that people that fly commercial or
demons
give me a chance to talk to eat heart
I'll explain there's nothing but its
meaning a calling old girl sweetheart
like that also bro hey you know this is
a 12-minute clip and he's standing on
the step of his Escalade the whole time
I think he likes the vantage point yeah
we wrestle not with other dudes penises
why our choir why are Christians so
offended by gay dudes you know let's not
go there
I just don't get it like not just well
religious people in general are just not
down with dudes sucking dick like that
in general is one of the worst things
that could ever imagine as a dude with
his dick in a mouth does it really
bobble there's a lot of things though
you don't I mean like it says don't eat
don't eat pork it says also is the gay
thing in the Old Testament because they
don't really care about that one you
know also they say this guy says in this
video everything is possible through
Christ sucking man's dick as possible
through Christ yet a little thing it's a
spiritual thing it doesn't have anything
to do with people people I love people
Jesus loves people I eat people people I
love people in alcohol do you think
that's a good place for a preacher to be
and prepare to go preach to a lot of
people when somebody in there is
dragging some woman down an aisle it
made me so mad to see that on television
I wanted to punch the guy out myself
[Music]
yeah he's talking about in he's talking
about like this United [ __ ] but he
wanted to punch the guy out himself that
doesn't happen every flight no you saw
it on television
yeah you weren't even there can you
imagine me a preacher being around
people drinking and a tube with David's
so you just don't like to be around the
sinful people or the the hurtful people
is that what you're saying to people
baby baby he's struggling we continue on
he asks her yes she asked do you use
your private jet for to lit to visit
your luxury homes because he says well I
need the jet to you know doom do my work
mm-hmm
and so she asks do you ever use your
private jets to go visit your vacation
home
for example yes okay again getting back
to the comment you said that you don't
like to fly commercial because you don't
want to get into a tube with a bunch of
demons do you really believe that human
beings are demons no I do not oh and
don't ever say I did yeah I want to get
that and then finally we've got should
preachers live a life of luxury so the
final question she keeps it really
aggressive but in there really like non
aggressive way she's strong and
confident and persistent but she doesn't
come off as like I'm your enemy and like
right because sometimes they when you
come off like that the other person will
just shut down and not even engage with
you but he is engaging somehow she
avoids like condescending or she's just
asked him you know I just want to know
about the to the demon with the tubes
are standing then about what you do and
prosperity preaching so the final
question is this to those critics that
say that a preacher should not be living
a life of luxury what is your response
to that they're wrong oh yeah baby just
like Jesus thought that it's a
misunderstanding listen to his
justification Bible that if you go into
the Old Covenant it's like two didn't
have you thought about this more I think
the Jewish is like making it up on the
spot broke I love you saying that Jewish
people appreciate money more than they
believe in wealth people would find that
offensive doesn't everyone want to be
rich I don't understand this Jewish
serious the Bible says Jews are [ __ ]
greedy grubby uh you know God and
trustworthy racks
covenant with God not it's not the
Jewish blessing it's the Abrahamic
blessing how'd I get excited talking
about it because I loved it and I
started out
deep in debt with Nana's physical which
is nosed or the night anyway he is the
night you say that it's biblical and
that that there's a foundation in the
Bible for that and he closed it with
this I I had to learn this like I said
from the Bible and from my spiritual
mentor Oral Roberts and I learned it
from him working with him and then we
became he was close friends until he
died and and he took the same heat for
brief heed God would prosper you that
I've taken over the years and Abraham
was very very wealthy man Galatians
chapter 3 if you belong to Christ then
are you Abraham's seed and heirs
according and he promised was great
wealth the Bible also says that it's
more difficult for a rich man to get
into heaven than it is for a camel to
get through the eye of a needle
correct rest of the scripture but he
said all things are possible with God
sound like that
that that's his that's his trump card he
also said so again he's like yes he said
this but I can I can do it what's like
an Magic the Gathering Dan when you do
like a card that reverses or
counterspell yeah he does the
counterspell but that's what I'm saying
like you can say that you know
homosexuality is a sin but you can
counter spell it with L things are
possible through God you know
counterspell [ __ ] we got to grab that
sound but the scripture but he said all
things are possible with God all things
are possible with God
I wish you would have followed up
okay preacher so does that mean that you
can suck a dick right now would you like
to prove that's possible I have a penis
would you like to suck it all things are
possible through God he's I got him and
[ __ ]
he said if you studied the Greek behind
that it's trusting in well I've seen
enough of this white walking creep Lance
Stewart music video number one on
trending I know
YouTube's are making an effort to put
creators more on the trending page but I
think we can all safely say this is not
what we met okay and like there was like
be love MOOC bang that was just so
probably one of our worst videos to even
her friends didn't like it and the funny
thing is like they're putting creators
on and but they're still not putting the
people on that like actually should be
there like be loves video had like
300,000 views everyone was saying why is
this number-one trending this is so
weird let me pull it up first let's
start with B love life the trash is is
possible yeah let me pull it up
literally it has a ton of dislikes just
from people being like why is this on
training and it was there for well she's
made a lot of content here it is let me
just skip to the middle it's a 30 minute
video let me just get a minute
here they go this was number one here
ending this is what YouTube is
broadcasting to the world this is it
guys can you imagine opening YouTube and
going number one trending and seeing of
this and like on the first minute she
has sauce on her face and they just
don't wipe it part of the deal
so this video started with like hundred
thousand is no cuts no editing yeah girl
like is this the lowest evolution of man
you know what I mean we're broadcasting
this to a million and a half well
beloved actually one of the biggest in
the game is almost 2 million people are
in the saw here starts yeah you could
see the sauce on her face like who
doesn't wipe their flight and a fridge
why are you drinking from a Red Solo Cup
oh did she die for a napkin no she's not
you know there's like a ton of [ __ ]
coming down your chin right they're not
even trying like yeah I can't so this
was number one trending for like two
days and then at the same time Lance
Stewart was number one trending with
this for like a full two days and so
they're really missing the point I mean
it's okay to trend these guys but you
still don't see the creators that we
were talking about who are like feed you
know somehow these guys are okay though
laughs baby Lance Stewart y'all know
Lance Stewart recently broke up with his
girlfriend we've discussed this on the
shows tragic hit me with that Zach it's
not easy
[Music]
see your silhouette inside my king-size
[Music]
number one trending baby I don't
understand
I'm not gonna break he had me started
with the court there's no fun
do dig you're halfway through the song
there's no verse in truth there's still
no verse okay no
here we go first otherwise
yeah the rap shirts without food [ __ ] no
he doesn't like to hurt
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you got to turn that up Zack it's
too quiet hit him with it
[Music]
yeah Paul was upset that it copied the
totally Rams angle dude
Jake Paul made a corny dumbass song that
literally sounded the same as this that
I'm single
Lance Stewart comes over the top with
I'm lost
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
he literally has one verse there's only
one bird man Lance is crazy
Lance has been up to all kinds of
shanigan lately too like he's been doing
a video where he creeps in bed what's
his uh creeps in bed with his dad
where's that one yeah oh maybe he erased
it because I don't he does a video where
he goes in bed uh I love you grandma oh
my god she what the [ __ ] is this he does
more he creeps in bed with his dad when
he's sleeping in cuddles and pretends to
be his mom and rubs his boner on his
dad's ass it's like super inappropriate
and then he did it to his grandma wait
move it I don't see it going down the
bradbury he's found it oh is this on his
channel or a discord wait is this was
this a real yes II know Lance Stewart Oh
what the hell April 19 so he's got a
chub right now and he's putting in his
dad's ass crack and finally before we
bring the guys out I want to say a happy
Memorial Day to our troops from pitbull
who made this tweet today we remembered
those who made the ultimate sacrifice
for America pitbull with a picture of
his face it's almost like he's saying he
died sacrificing for America what the
what were you thinking man why would you
honor the troops and tweet your face
damn it is from 2000 something right 17
yes 17 no this is immortal just to rest
in peace pitbull died serving our
country on the USS McCain mr. right
there mr. worldwide
god bless his soul man we'll miss his
music but his heart wait like that come
to happen like dizzy request that
Photoshop from one of his assistants or
that's such a great question nila or he
has such genius assistant that they made
it for it I think they probably made it
for him
here's a memorial date wait for you
that's a tough question but I also feel
like pitbull was like you know I really
want to honor the troops this year just
put some like American flag in me and I
really want to honor the troops this
year so there you have it rest in peace
pitbull mr. worldwide lost but not
forgotten a war hero guys it's time for
a break but when we come back we're
bringing the boys out bring in out we're
bringing a Dan out there no memes left
behind we've got a ton ton ton of stuff
here do not go away we shall return
shortly
it's dinnertime your stomach is rumbling
but you don't know what you're gonna eat
tonight does that sound familiar ela yes
all too familiar but with door - you
don't need to get up from the couch you
don't have to worry about what you're
gonna eat you don't this stop at the
grocery store because you're tired and
you deserve a nice hot meal delivered to
your dang door
that's what staying in freakin door - is
all about door - connects to your
favorite restaurant in your city
ordering is easy you just use the door -
app you choose what you want to eat and
that Dasher will bring it to you
anywhere you are not only is that burger
place you love on door - already but
over three hundred and ten thousand
other amazing restaurants are - door -
connects you with door to door delivery
in over 3,300 cities all 50 states and
canada I'm amazed at the breadth that of
restaurants that are on the door -
because you can pretty much find
whatever you're looking for on this app
you can order from your local go to or
choose from your favorite chains like
Chipotle Wendy's chick-fil-a and the
Cheesecake Factory boy don't worry about
dinner let dinner come to you with door
- and listen to this this is a great
offer right now our listeners can get
five dollars off the first order of $15
or more that's just a free five dollars
to your favorite restaurant guys with
the door - app download the door - app
and enter promo code h3 so that's five
dollars off your first order when you
download the door - app from the App
Store enter promo code h3 again that's
the promo code h3 for five dollars off
your first order from door -
there's something bold and beautiful
about how a custom-made suit fits a
man's body
he looks like an Adonis before if you
get it off the rack you look like a
doofus banker a banker yes every man
looks and feels more confidently who
puts on a custom-made suit endo Chino is
the world's most exciting made to
measure men's wear company they make
suits and shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort here's how it works you visit
one of their showrooms they have over 40
in North America and have them take your
measurements personally or you can
measure at home yourself and shop online
at endo Chino comm you choose your
fabric inside and out you choose your
design customization you submit your
measurements with your choices and you
kick back while your suit gets
professionally tailored and mailed to
you in a couple of weeks this week my
listeners can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just 379th region $79 at Indo
Chino comm when entering h3 podcasts out
check out that is a ridiculous deal for
a custom-made suit these things lost
your life time you look sharp you look
beautiful you are gonna get your dick
soaking wet right EULA that's 50% off
the regular price of a made-to-measure
premium suit plus guys the shipping is
free
that's Indo Chino dot-com promo code h3
podcast for any premium suit for just
three hundred and seventy one dollars
and free shipping incredible deal for
premium made-to-measure suit
once you go custom you don't go back
that's Indo Chino I and do CH I and O
calm use promo code h3 podcast
you know those times when every day
feels the same like you're on autopilot
how you're so caught up in your routine
that you forget to take care of yourself
while Dollar Shave Club makes it easy to
take care of yourself even when you're
critically depressed their quality
products help me look for you and smell
my best I get everything I need from
Dollar Shave Club without going to the
store I've been a dollar club shaved
member for years they've graciously
supported our channel and provided me
with this meaty beautiful razor that is
second to none I do not get razor burns
from this it's meaty it's beefy it's hot
I love this it's one of the best do it
it weighs like a freaking pound you can
feel you could use as a weapon even as a
murder weapon potentially if you want if
you were so inclined also don't even get
me started on their shave but oh dude
they've got the shave butter that you
lather your face up before you shave and
let me tell you it is like butter it is
butter they've got a face wash that just
leaves your face feeling so clean and
beautiful afterwards it's ridiculous
it's the Dollar Shave Club experience
baby they're not just razors they got it
all body while shampoo toothpaste you
name it they've got it
Dollar Shave Club I spent years
developing crafting refining their
products there's so much better than
anything I've ever used before and
they're sent right to your door so they
even though you're depressed and you
don't want to leave your house you could
still keep it clean and keep it together
with Dollar Shave Club and right now you
can get a Dollar Shave Club starter set
for just $5 it comes with everything you
need for a great shave the executive
razor the shave butter the face cleanser
you're gonna love it as much as I do get
your starter set for just $5 at
dollarshaveclub.com slash HP that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash h3
we are back with the gang here with Dan
the producer here we are within the
intern forever the intern how are you
guys feeling today doing well I'm good
for the behavior I'm blessed
feeling blessed plus um Ian your
birthday's tomorrow yes congratulations
the big 53 is it is a big one over and
out what scary
25 25 to do the mental math
how do you feel about the being a
quarter of a century old yeah I get up
something happens at 25 right you can
run a car currently oh you can get the
real car you can rent a car already but
you get a greatly reduced rate now that
that's that's good that's huge
you're gonna start waking up more
frequently in the evening to pee mm-hmm
have you noticed that happening down oh
yeah so that's gonna be something I wake
up a lot dude I'm gonna be so [ __ ] on
I'm 70 I fantasized I don't know if I've
talked about this on air but I've often
fantasized through my life of a hole
through the bed that's suck this has a
vacuum that you put your dick in the
hole and then it goes directly to
plumbing so you can just roll over here
in your bed and pee and your dad
built-in catheter basically yeah yeah
it's yeah but you just put your dick in
it okay I'll hold there's no needle no
no we should probably cut this out cuz
we don't want someone to take the idea
that's a really good I'm not doing I
want someone to take that you know I
don't wanna it's not I don't you know
run with the baby I'll podcast a few if
you invent that what about in the car
would not be a good idea in the car just
stopped the car Zak what the hell yeah
not animals come on Zach we're not
animals
no I'm kidding that's okay idea I feel
like people are more equipped for that
Oh in honor of your birthday by the way
Zach we did get you a present exact in
in honor of your birthday we got you I
didn't want you to think we forgot we
got you a Sharky's gift you guys may
remember the fiasco [ __ ] gift card
we got you a hundred dollars on a lot of
salmon burritos right there since I
spent the last one I've never gone back
so thank you for bringing me back to
that place bring a date you know yeah
yeah
salmon burritos all around treater how
was your love life going by the way
masks you know let's talk about how are
you doing Dan let's talk about your love
life
that's not Dan how's your love life
going it's all right it's all right
yeah you [ __ ] our Asian know I don't
know but you do do you get around and
ring a little how would you go on a date
what like how many days are we talking
before you sleep with her or like like
what's your policy you can you have one
it's gonna sound bad but it's fine we're
grown-ups there's really no there's no
restriction yeah there's no restriction
I wouldn't have a striction so first
date let's say on average ii ii ii ii is
usually that's respectful I mean in this
state the day and age of tinder yeah
Jesus anything is possible and and
what's the okay good for you good and
how many are we up to these days I'd
rather not say I'll skip that one I
think Dan is somewhere that I think he's
doing well
dan is a coke up close to 20 I would
guess 20 just like a grand total
lifetime yeah yeah there you have it
it's not bad and in someone that's
watching that you're afraid of like what
do you what are you anxious about or who
is it that you don't want to hear no not
bad though my mom does watch a lot are
you are you currently seeing someone
that you don't do you think I'm not I'm
not like dating but there's someone that
you are
currently interested in yeah and is she
a fan of the show so is that why we're
being more delicate around the issue
there's some memes that I think they
left behind we got go rescue and it's
not your show you don't get to control
the page all right I see it's a
sensitive issue yeah yeah it's
liberating yeah I don't care my parents
what you just got to get over it you
know my mom doesn't watch too much
my dad pops in occasionally though you
can't let that get in your head I mean
Oriole yeah like I ela you have this
problem with we film h3 videos every
time we just sit down the record you go
all I'm thinking about is what my
parents would yeah yeah I mean for
example I'll just say I have a tiny
penis that barely works the pubes are
longer than the penis itself
Wow so immature turn you have that ready
locked and loaded
all right can't you can't you can't
force a man to - yeah I'm not asking for
your dick size I do I would like to know
more about your sex life but another
time do you date girls that vape Danah
would you ever yeah no that's I put that
in my profile if you if you ain't vaping
well because you you do vape a lot so I
wonder do girls mind that you vape ever
I I don't like lie about it but I
definitely don't put that it's not out
front right it's not hard it's not the
sexiest habit sure I mean it's better
than smoking it is better than smoking
so when you when you go on a first date
do you vape do you bring your vapor do
you leave it at home I'll leave it in
the car you know that's good use a
little bit more tact
yeah I mean truth be told if if I could
quit everything tomorrow I would
but you know it's it's I started it as a
crutch to quit smoking which was
successful haven't had a cigarette in a
long time but yeah like you know if I
could just not do anything that that
would obviously be preferable well you
know I did watch a documentary like a
big BBC documentary about vaping and
they did all kinds of tests like on
lungs and elevated like carcinogens in
the blood and all this and vaping was
way less harmful than smoking they found
ya know that doesn't surprise me at all
I mean unless you know 20 years from now
we find out that there's like long
long-term damage happening I mean the
the immediate benefits are apparent to
anybody that does it I mean I my lung
capacity is 20 times what it was when I
spoke cigarettes so just that alone
being able to go upstairs without being
out of breath is nice that's very
wonderful leave that at home though I
guess when you're on the the first day
at what point do you whip out the baby
and just be like baby I gotta tell you
something right after the sex yeah okay
in you go I guess you don't really have
anything to add I've never vaped ever
we don't even tried it no well let's get
you addicted hi dude let's go you've
never spent your generation is way more
cool with it they're all like Julie and
[ __ ] I'm like I'm secondhand vaping next
to damn all smoke well with that being
said let's go ahead with no memes left
behind we've got a lot to get to so
let's just get started let's get right
into it
now I'll go first Eva we are continuing
the bad tattoos ela has put forth a
theory that there's no worse tattoo on
this planet than Ben Affleck's back
tattoo do you want to briefly kind of
explain your thesis on that basically
what you need to know is that we take
into consideration the full package of
him being Ben Affleck right you got it
I think in his 40s
you had to lie about it for us because
he was so ashamed of it he said he got
it for a movie and then a year later
they who was photographed with it yeah
those are the main factors now I think
it's a female thing because although I
agree it's corny as hell I mean I could
admire the artistry of the tattoo itself
but we had other females in the office
and they unanimously agreed that there
was that this was truly a terror I mean
they're like they've reacted stronger to
it then the guys than the guys yeah 100
but with that being said we've been on a
mission out to find a tattoo that is
worse in the eyes of Elah that is worse
than Ivo before we began actually chris
d'elia
is on record defending Ben Affleck I
just remembered what happened was
[ __ ] Ben Affleck's back tattoo you
saw that dude okay look I actually I
like Ben Affleck I think he's in cool
movies I [ __ ] I think he's good he's
a good director I I [ __ ] liked him as
Batman I know I think that's the
unpopular opinion but I thought he was
holy [ __ ] as Batman he lives there he's
[ __ ] got cool grey hairs that's how I
say is great as bad who's Wayne should
be you just never go [ __ ] yourself and
that back tattoo look who gives a [ __ ]
if a back tattoo is what someone else
likes you gotta like it fine can't see
the funniest [ __ ] though was they were
making fun of it and he said no it's
just for a movie yeah and then years
later they got a picture with him with
the tattoo on I don't quite get what is
that part on the bottom under the wing
that's not attached to the Phoenix the
feather falling the weird like yeah I
think it's a tail yeah what is that
why not canary it's not very
oh there's wood bricks in it yeah that
is weird
it's a detail which means residence ID
identifies with that it was just over at
school the fact that it dude I don't
understand this do you know the story of
the Phoenix suit it's a bird that burns
itself it burns itself dies and from its
ashes is reborn again so it lives
forever through this cycle of dying and
being born again from its own ashes like
Ben Affleck mm-hmm
like the Netflix career tattoo sucks to
me there you go you like go I go I go in
your face there I close the distance and
I say this back tattoo is the [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude guess what I happen to think
that back tattoo I happen to think I
don't I I think it's ugly
okay opinion if if Ben Affleck came out
with a video that said hey you know [ __ ]
about my back tattoo I know a lot of you
guys don't like a back tattoo but I just
got one thing to say to you guys I agree
with the message you do yeah well that's
what made it worse for sure that he had
to lie but at the time you put this
whole thing over you back by the way
that's like a hundred hours under the
needle right I mean that's that's when
just a lie that's so easily disproven
it's like oh yeah it's just temporary
never be she's like yeah you just never
show you back everything at that point
well so at any rate let's continue
that's the backstory ELA are you ready
that is the back story thank you so some
of these are too explicit to show so I
kind of need to show yes I don't know
how to do this oh god this myself [ __ ] I
can't show that right I can tell you I
could show this one it shows it dude
it's armpit now is this meant to be a
joke or does he want people
[ __ ] his armpit you know I mean cuz if
that guy goes to first I feel like
people will put their dick in his armpit
I didn't even think about that
so maybe he wants you to actually put
his dick there Don Sela it's definitely
awful but the delineation their eyes
when they're trying to be funny you
think it's not as bad
right it's I do I think it makes a big
difference but this one is you - rancid
almost the size of the tattoo of Ben
Affleck it's the size of the difference
and so but I think that only goes so far
though like this guy's undateable
forever like any self-respecting yeah
but in prison very popular yeah
backing it up for this guy he's got a
tattoo on the back of his head
he's on a cure point so this is the
person behind him in us to stare that
face on the back of his head that is
basically shocked to see that is
committed to the haircut
- because why why why why [ __ ]
hilarious
but why would you commit your whole life
to like owning that I wonder if it just
does it for the plane ride to [ __ ] with
the person but you know even has like it
looks like hair on the forehead creases
I don't know if that's just the tattoo
or oh that's a good point yeah crazy
[Laughter]
this guy got a bunch of emojis on his
arm that is what was bad apparently he
has the shirt on but he actually has
dedicate himself to getting every emoji
so like under the eye it's just all the
emojis that exist while they're adding
emojis so this guy's in trouble and this
guy I mean this guy's got to be a little
bit of a contender cuz he's a basketball
player he's not his famous Ben Affleck
but it's not this like I agree but it's
not as bad
fair enough but what's he gonna do like
they changed the squirt gun or they
change the real gun to the scorpion does
that mean he gets his tattoo removed I
get it removed laser edit it yeah
I'm really careful because this guy just
got a huge monster on his back that's oh
that's Rob right
yeah that's Rob no this is the
ridiculous
that worse Wow yeah he loves monster
baby we own the company no absolutely
not not own but he must have some sort
of brand deal he's a rich [ __ ] guy I
mean how much can you pay a guy is
already rich to get a huge tattoo of
monster on his back I mean that guy's a
family [ __ ] he's got a walk around
what's off presumably takes his shirt
off you know at the pool and at the
beach and stuff like that sure so how
does this compare to Ben's it might be
worse I think that's what's up there huh
yeah there you have it Rob I don't like
Rob dear I don't like that I don't like
ridiculousness he might be a fine guy
but Rob a big was a fun show back in
yeah I mean that was [ __ ] 15 years
ago now and I used to watch Fantasy
Factory that show he had where he just
messed around in that warehouse downtown
dude oh yeah so here you go here you
have it I think we have a winner and
he's even celebrating in the photo so
either here you have ladies love it
overs upper lip wow this guy's like this
is the only way I'm getting that is hot
I just got to advertise it ladies love
it
and he could cut what if he grows his
moustache then he's you can cover that
yeah you can affect it
this guy got I mean it's not bad yeah I
mean it is but I mean compared to this
so there's one I'm really being careful
here I think that one might be the the
really bad ones that I think you're
talking about
at the very bottom ones just a dog this
one's I think my problem is that the Ben
Affleck one just it was my first one
then kind of like it's like your first
experience yeah it's so iconic for me
now yeah here this is the one this is
the real one that and I don't think I
can show this on screen so grab why
don't you just come peek behind my
shoulder yeah it's it's so this is a
female with a she's not nude but she has
a baby like Anna maybe that's not bad
that shocked the hell up so she's got an
anime baby tattooed over a baby Beulah
that's a baby come here look at the
breasts it's a it's a baby that she's
wearing like a diaper when she has oh
it's a baby like an anime baby tattooed
over her genitals so it looks like when
you're having sex with her that you're
having sex with a baby
yeah people want to see this which I
don't know why you would want to it this
was submitted to us on our on our
Twitter on the podcast Twitter and we
named out a call for these tattoos so if
you want to see what we're talking about
go check it out there she has like the
baby has tattoos and stuff so it's a
hardcore baby yeah my first reaction was
like I mean it's like it's like
someone's gonna be into it it's a style
that someone's gonna be into somebody
dude I don't you when you have sex with
her you're having sex with a child I
guess it yeah that part makes it super
weird you surprised me I don't know I
find the monster think he's been deeper
drag it down I gotta let me sleep on it
yeah I can't I think they could cheer
their backgrounds yeah yeah the fact
that they're both celebs Ben Affleck
though was like it's worse because Ben
Affleck's like a leading man yeah
heartthrobs so good and Rob is like a
doofus and you do have that factor of
Ben being ashamed of his and Rob clearly
being very proud of his so I mean that
does that give us a couple of Ben yeah
well Robbie second clear second throw
over the baby over the genitals yeah I
think so
Wow because it's not just a baby I don't
know it's like an anime character and
that your thoughts on that armpit vagina
the baby's worse than our paper China I
mean I don't know I figured getting in
my head I think I have to say that the
baby's worse just rank you've got four
you've got the baby vagina I got the
armpit vagina you've got Rob and you got
been so place those and we had the place
those five well I'm doing celebrities
first go ahead so Ben um hey you gotta
go down actually second over Rob yeah
and then and then between the between
the baby vagina the armpit vagina and
then there was also the goat hole what
was that the cow whole cow hole yeah
that one's a fan-favorite it keeps
getting used to minute to me by
different people I don't think the cow
hole is up there you found that funny
bad guys probably a legend yeah well
compared to like I think you Ethan would
probably like to hang out with that guy
I don't here's the tattoo in question so
cavernous that's what I don't know
gaping good that's so nasty I don't want
to hang up and the end they're like big
utters are like trippin cow was rotting
off of the couch yeah cuz this cow has
been used sexually yeah I think that's
what it's implying yeah and I think also
was he playing that he wants someone to
put his deck and his belly button
all right let's move it off thank you
Elam
we did we did pretty good that time
better than the last round yeah yeah
that was some compelling stuff yeah we
had some contenders at least now so why
do you guys thing about the armpit
versus damn the baby ones I find the
fatality anything both were like I mean
I imagine putting that over your
genitals yeah the baby was it's look
like a baby right away to me
okay even still I mean it's just
unfathomable like how [ __ ] up in the
head you have to be getting that
tattooed seriously yeah it wasn't a baby
like just anything there you're like
having sex and there's like a thing
that's right yeah in that in place of
that that's just weird
yeah but also it's a baby yeah one of
the worst I want to see why got Yakuza
like badass baby though yeah so so she
likes it I would like to see just a
garbage can around someone's vagina
hi it's probably out there doing this
segment has taught me that there's a it
exists all right this next segment is
directed towards you and does your the
Kim Kardashian Kanye expert they need to
start paying me for all this PR I'm
doing that is true
I'm for that and I'm totally for that
Kim Kardashian tweeted this out and I
was like was holy unhinge man Kim
Kardashian tweeted she said hey
jack-in-the-box
I have a serious complaint but I won't
fully put you on blast check your
corporate email inbox or send me a DM
with direct person for my team to
contact pronto that's some straight-up
like angry white mom [ __ ] yeah that's
like that's like Kardashian mafia will
be at your door Jack I don't know but I
I need to know what happened what
everyone needs to know what happens I
can't I can't imagine it's just like oh
yeah I ordered a certain burger and I
got the wrong you know wrong serious yes
this complaint I'm so some went down
like I have a feeling it's not that
serious serious could have been a jacket
long that serious go to the police
not Twitter right if she's going to
Twitter about it it's like the wrong
sauce yeah I think too much ketchup go
to Twitter maybe they deemed her and
then she just replied with a picture of
like in-and-out burger was like this is
why you had your old [ __ ] yeah your
place sucks
it's low on the tier list does anyone
say pronto yeah I was gonna say the
pronto is what pushed it over the top so
entitled yeah like why did what do you
think about I mean she seems like a
psycho entitled crazy person to me
calling out jack in the box with the
pronto Ian like I said I gotta know what
happened I need the facts yeah I need
the info so if her fries were like
overcooked if it's something if it's
unrelated to food I think that's a
little overdramatic but maybe if an
employee like you know I grabbed or hot
[ __ ] or something who God knows what you
know so if that happened that's okay
maybe actually if like uh if if like an
employee grabbed her ass but why you
gonna blame jack-in-the-box just call
the police
yeah cuz it you can't hold the
perpetrator corporate responsible for
but I guess not great okay then just
like if she was like someone verbally
said something to her like an employee I
think you got to move on with your life
you don't have we corporate probably
like she got to feel so powerful that
she can get corporate to like put this
guy in their burgers you know yeah but
there you have it so this is saying I
won't put you on blast so it means that
like it's something about the company
right cuz I think what I think being
vague is almost worse though right it
lets people assume the worst
yeah you know it gives people like Ian
here wiggle room stand out we don't have
the fact
so this started an avalanche of activity
all these fast-food Twitter accounts
would are so edgy and hilarious got in
on it who are I have a theory is run by
the same person
this is so cringy I'm just not down I
think everyone needs to stop engaging
why he's fast food I [ __ ] hate this
yeah I really do this is the worst
let's see shake check with the eyes
Burger King with jack-in-the-box to the
principal's office
Gotham Carl's jr. with Psalm 520 they'll
teach AK in the Box steak um bro
what is your what even is your name
steak um is that steak is that really
stake him why are you going to
jack-in-the-box Lowell wow that was not
the most clever response Hooters is even
on this your hooters you are hooters you
hire waitresses with big boobs and your
name is Hooters like not a good day to
be jack it's never a good day to be
Hooters your hooter
there's nothing going on about that
place I would rather [ __ ] cut my dick
off than step foot in Hooters Wendy's
but like who even goes there shut up
dude when is the sassiest I've noticed
they're very sassy over Wendy they kinda
I don't know if they invented it but
they're the first pretty much yeah those
guys and pizza shake my head definitely
not the move burgerfi we're here for you
dude you're not gonna try be fun oh god
I know so lots of activity here I have a
theory that it's just one dude running
all these you know I haven't food I've
it there he's like some four year old
dude who's trying to act like a 13 year
old you know I read a the Wendy's person
didn't AMA you can find oh yeah a
younger female who was doing it no way
kind of at the beginning and then they
they're like [ __ ] you need to go yeah
in the name Buckcherry now it's like a
team jacket and then I found out Jack in
the Box to the Lele palms to commercial
and I mean
this is really high production they
tweeted it out it only has 200 likes
mm-hmm so this was kind of like oh I'm
gonna make my chicken bigger tastier the
best are you kidding me I was literally
born for this you're born into a a
jack-in-the-box commercial so you had me
at Ferrari pacifier try my new spicy
chicken straight all white meat chicken
for just $4.99 just $4.99 oh man I think
all of that stucks thank you yeah
thank you Dan as 150,000 views so
despite the lack of likes but uh are you
guys only in the States
yes we are the next response is I'm
boycotting you for this and then the
next person has a picture of they said I
got the 5 piece and I don't know why I
bother anymore it included a picture of
the saddest-looking nuggets I've ever
seen in my second hive box oasis they
suck again much worse
what do we when we rated were they down
the bottom was that like a I put it
there F yeah from now that's right yeah
they're awful people eat Jacqueline box
tacos are creeps yeah maybe that was
Kim's complaint she saw this ad was like
this has got to go lay off here and then
and then kind of going down the Kim hole
I found out that Kim Kardashian the Kim
hole going down the camel Kim Kardashian
oh man
it's closed you know the eBay thing
uh-huh
so Kim it's closed now I wish way back
but she was selling her used clothes on
eBay
yeah I remember when that was probably
on my phone but that would take so long
why uh I think well she links it like
some of the purse
for for charity okay but it was only
some lovely people say that too like how
much 10% what it's still a freaking and
yeah you know let me see if I can find
out how I do have a let's see here I got
way back machine what we got here
but she's selling a mother I have a
frickin Frick frack
but she's selling like normal clothes is
like not reasonably priced - yeah she
just trying to make a quick buck selling
our used clothing I mean you said she's
donating it right not all of it oh
really
she didn't I don't remember what the
split was a donation on her Instagram
and that wasn't a big part of it I cuz
that wasn't something that I noticed oh
by the way this podcast every we donate
a part of our proceeds charity every
year we do a fundraiser it's all about
the charity yeah I don't make money I
make a little bit but it's all for
charity right it was odd I mean some of
this stuff is like a shirt for like 50
bucks
why is Kim bothering to sell a shirt for
50 bucks
why no was it all like designer yeah
yeah yeah she probably gets given
designer clothes for free cause you're
looking to make about something yeah
hundred million dollars you don't become
a billionaire you know well I was
thinking about buying some underwear and
smelling it did you think about that she
was something used underwear wow that
one was like five thousand though was
she
I don't know but I was thinking like all
these creeps are just getting in
sniffing it ya know I don't know you
sure I'm sure
okay you would not sniffer used
underwear nope I have a respect for that
couple and that relationship and would
you rate him on a scale of one to ten I
don't find her attractive what would you
rate her on one because well I was
London Danny and well I gotta give them
first the basis okay i feei was talking
to my roommate the other day about this
she's gone past a point of like typical
an attraction because she's like this
come on
sorry no I'm just saying the like she's
like a kid caricature at this point and
it's not I don't have any feeling in
that way anymore not even close he's not
really she's she's not a human she's not
humanized yeah something like that it's
kind of yeah one to tenean mmm what it
looks yeah can we do a round robin was
that mean yeah what is that
well you go what do you got Ian stop
give me an answer one two that I don't
know because I just give me a number one
to ten I just break down crying give me
a number
all right I'll say I'll say seven okay
that's so disrespectful dude what the
[ __ ]
seven said hi I mean yeah that's a high
rating well I'm calculating for I'm
calculating for well a lot of people are
attracted to her and she's attractive to
most sevens fine I agree with seven yeah
let's go say six but yeah he's not a
sick she's a seven thank you disagree
although when I fantasize about having
sex with her it doesn't even work as my
dick is so small I knew I couldn't give
it a pass her butt cheeks but for me I
can't like it goes down like have you
thought about that
dick just have sex with their cuz their
ass cheeks are like six inches long have
you thought about that again I haven't
calculated for that one yes pretty wild
so weird I know I took screenshots of
all that find it yeah it's fine there's
really nothing to see yeah so and then
finally going down the Kim hole
this is a some excerpts from her vogue
behind the scenes for the Met Gala
outfit which I didn't particularly care
for but there was some moments here that
I think I was ready
mini doughnuts my favorite doughnuts
ever from New York and I eat a dozen by
myself but they're literally like this
big there's there many many many which
is I think that dozen probably equals
like one regular donor sure I don't want
anyone to think that I eat yeah I got so
here they are putting her in the corset
and stuffing her skin next and the ORS
of beauty we work with the best
creatures you can aren't really used to
build the best corset make a little
stuff in your skin right it's like
having a whole tingling talking where
her nipples I guess it must be like
right yeah because right in coz there's
not that much face like that's not
exposed it's true so her nips must be
right [ __ ] on the edge right here
whatever you say
so look at her waist man oh Jesus
she can't sit how crazy is that better
than [ __ ] I'm not on mine that can't be
healthy
look the wet look could they not think
of a better name for it okay
the wet like silicone so take not latex
she's like unfortunately after doing
this I am unable to have children I
don't steal with what I see is exhumed
Egyptian pharaoh are a corpse corpse
yeah that's [ __ ] weird
I can't that shot of her like that
disturbed me and I think I was not good
to do over here yeah maybe this I've
ever seen a team like this before yeah
look at her waist like Chris is like
beyond I don't really like the outfit
frankly speaking there I don't really
like this collar and everything yeah do
you like the outfit I do you're such a
[ __ ] lame-o dude because I like an
outfit no because you're riding her dick
you won't have you won't have a car
honest conversation with me you dodge
every question I gave you I don't
believe you let me tell you what I think
you know let me tell you what I think
but sir I think that you're so afraid of
the Kanye community hearing you say a
single bad thing about camera Kanye even
if you happen to think it we're here to
have an open frank conversation about
these things and you're too afraid of
what the community thinks of you that
you're not willing to ever say anything
and critical of them in that's what I
think is that it you good yeah no I I
like the design I like the the little
droplets it like gives it like this
water
look I thought that was cool I haven't
seen something like that before I
thought it was an interesting look such
a dick riderhood I would say if it was
bad what do you think about Mannion's
outfit what is that well then mat gone
here let me pull it up
oh is his security guard look can well
he said to Matt go ahead he said his
reasoning for doing that was because I
just saw it yeah yeah yeah
so here's jacket dollar stove actually
he said it was because the very first
one that he went to Kim was his plus one
she wasn't even invited and so it was
all about him and then this is this one
she was actually invited and so he said
I'm gonna be your plus-one and I'm gonna
not do it this is all your night so I'm
just gonna pull back and and you know
let you have the shine so that's why he
dressed like that as a sweet thing for
him to have done for his wife is it or
did he steal the attention by being
stolen looking like the janitor at the
gala yeah actually he didn't really
steal the attention I do think it was
funny what I did I think they could have
a little coordinated better like it did
it's a little too unlike just what is
wearing so you don't think like the the
fake water look it looks like her hair
is all kind of wet in the drips you
don't think that it doesn't work for me
okay I see what they were going forward
that family cuz then she has a second
outfit of the night where she's all like
ice yeah I didn't see that one
Kim Met Gala ice like a frickin extra
from frozen on ice she looks like Cher
it's big cher fan
how was her way still like that one
she's not wearing what she's so I think
she is she must be wearing of course I
don't think in fact what I would guess
Dan is that this isn't actually
transparent Oh fake yeah button and
she's actually wearing a course oh
you're probably right oh you can kind of
see where the skin breaks yeah okay
I explained okay I get your reasoning
yeah I get your reasoning yeah fair
enough
all right let's move it along because
it's taking a lot we've all been going
for hour and a half yeah I wonder how
we're gonna get to everything do it
let me just skip let me just skip ahead
to the see we're all ready we're leaving
memes behind I have a lot of good [ __ ]
here but why is the camera so close this
one we must watch this is from Quentin
Tarantino's new film premiered in Cannes
can't hang pants and the fan that
everybody liked it so we got a standing
O look at the tradition they're just
standing though and they do it for like
20 minutes 30 it's like I said notches
weird things like a wondering why do
they literally just stand there in
silence what do you I was
it's like a human experiment like a such
a parent but anyway the cameraman goes
off the rails and he burns the camera so
close to their faces it's just pure
unadulterated beautiful cringe she's
just she's like what the hell and he you
know keeps getting closer they have it
your turn now then when you think it
can't get closer he continues to step
for it
oh my god my friend she's like posing
for you kids going it's almost like
they're collaborating to make it as
uncomfortable as possible like the
audience clapping the cameraman it's so
close here we go closer closer closer
because the camera manner is the
director in his ears like giving him
Poona yeah but he's like an inch away
from his face and you can act
yo get in frame his whole face to see
the full shot of it here closer baby
closer coward it's just bizarre
all right let's bring it in Schneider
tighter tighter yeah it could be the
directories like tighter tighter the
guys like I'm gonna that's this Israeli
way like with the real yeah closer baby
tighter tighter tighter tighter the
directors in his ear like I don't think
I could clap for that one in my hands
your hands with her it's so 1/2 minute
masturbatory what do you then that's
heard that is a legend he is as if they
got the tattoo on his boat this is her
dad he looks like a damn Ozzy Osbourne
yeah wait hurt wait why does it look
like her job he look like why are Tina
oh no way
why should try to [ __ ] your dad right
now am I crazy or is that literally her
dad I've never seen Quentin with this
hair like written all of a sudden who's
that Quinton though that's Quentin get a
load of that lace all right that is him
huh is it a Photoshop I've never seen
him that's not a photo op my dudes
that's real so how old is she yeah she's
like 27 I'm 29
I don't know something eats up oh that's
her debt what's her name you Danielle a
peek Danielle a peek age wait daddy
let me type Israeli oh she's 35 what
city what in a while since I've been to
Israel sweet yeah whatever feet look
like what surprised me
let's see if we can find out let's see
what's your name daniella peak a feet
do not know why I'm asking that no no
you don't know why I'm asking that it
seems super weird no it's when tarantino
famously has a foot fetish well let's
see if we can peep her feet she's
walking around barefoot they're perfect
of course she is
dan probably insist oh she's got a high
heels that looked like they're invisible
no he's so into that what do you think
of Quentin's Jean dad shoe combo I'm
into it you are it's funny I think that
as you go I thought here I thought it
was fine did I'll tell you what I would
I would I would jizz on her feet yeah
would you oh for sure yeah your toes are
a little long for my taste really what
would you rate her feet I think she's
not really would not date her
I'm not kidding he wouldn't date her if
she didn't so I don't have like I don't
really understand foot fetish but I mean
she's gotten it's one of the weirdest
happens opposite I can't stand fit right
ant I thank you I like that's like one
of the more common weird fetishes though
like not like no if you can calm
somewhat like relatively common compared
to a lot of others mm-hmm and then in
the oldest Quentin Quinn Quinn [ __ ]
hell
Tarantino 5760 bro 56 mm-hmm
so what's that a 20-year age difference
that's 11 years 35 is fine Holden hosts
30 whatever you know what I mean like
songs you got nice feet I'm down mmm he
probably has like a prenup with her
where it's like if anything happens to
her feet right the marriage is off gosh
the bad kisser you know I just don't
have time I got to pass this off so
that's it for me all right I hope you
all enjoyed my segment I contributions
here yeah we're gonna have to your ear
hold these these next ones we don't get
time to for next time cuz there should
be no memes left behind but until then
hila let's give a round of
all right so we've got Ethan Bradberry
Ethan Bradberry and I think I think just
us have already watched it like a
thousand times it's honestly such a
trend of obsessed this video only has
7,000 views I mean the regula is the new
slammin yeah the in and I quote it
constantly here the other B then a
second but first I need to introduce
these guys in a second I'm not gonna be
read about if I'm gonna get back to them
in a few chairs chase so this is what we
got going on over here we're on a
mission today we're New York City I'm
Brooklyn to be exact we're trying to
find the Roth of the wrong guys Wonder
snail what that is in a few seconds I'll
show the clips of that all right it's
never really made clear what the Rost of
the Rye understand what it is okay so
what he's talking about is raw coffee
bean so he's looking for he's got
because I've been following my Instagram
his interest stories and everything he's
always showing him blending raw coffee
beans no not he's on a kick where he
doesn't believe in getting like
pre-ground or pre-processed so he puts
the raw coffee bean in a blender and
then he puts it straight into the coffee
machine so that's why he calls it the
Rost of the raw okay what they call it I
think it's a joke amongst himself I love
that Ethan this video is so not
explained and they have this whole code
of talking with each other where they go
they I just act like they're Italian
mobsters I don't know why they're
obsessed with that again
yeah but what I've deciphered is that
they started doing this Ross of the raw
the raw coffee bean and they call it the
regular so they said what do you want
all of the regular so they call it the
regula yeah so the regula is raw as the
ross of the row which is kind of gives
you the the language you need to
understand this was good in slam on them
with the regular schmegle on that's what
we got going on over here how do you kid
and what are you out of your mind so
it's it doesn't make sense you get it
what do you mind I didn't say anything
so we got brewing over here no not that
intense music I know in adduction
for those of you who don't know me that
is what we're gonna do I'm gonna roll
clips of the regular right here because
that's our mission to find he's gonna
roll clips of the regular right here the
problem with this video and Ethan I hit
I think I can help you is that you're
basically making an inside joke with
your friends which is funny but you're
not letting us in on on the joke the
context of the joke so it's funny I mean
it's kind of funny the train wreck just
because you don't know what's happening
but I think he does need to work on
setting it up a little bit more right
for for it to be shareable because not
everyone is willing to watch it a
hundred times like made it but that's
why I'm here even because we're here to
support you and we love you maybe that's
the appeal it's like a puzzle you have
to keep going in and I was gonna say I
mean it kind of the mystery element is
it is you uncover new information each
each why we're gonna slam them with the
regular here we go here we go
slamming with the regula
we go I got a they got a mr. coffee but
this is what we got going on over here
where's the fifth cup it's we're gonna
walk into a raw shop the regular we're
gonna slam them with it a couple of them
well you didn't want to waste for the
guy we're gonna slam them with a regular
there we go a couple wise guys it's
gonna happen it's like they're just
grunting it sound like the loss of
Raptors so this is when it gets really
good once where's the owl intro wait a
minute coming the Bradbury owl I don't
know what is ready and now they start
doing all this crazy b-roll of the city
like man it's just your production here
we are in a star of the raw shop it's a
rush job
[Music]
have you been good
let me get the regular size the you got
the regular regular
Megillah this guy knows he's gonna be
killed possibly right okay
his name's Bo
or shadows Megillah we just got regular
coffee here yeah
maybe she might know it's been all the
regulars Megillah this is what happens
when they don't fake pranks yeah exactly
that's a good point I think a bribe then
they really did go they set this up and
they went through the whole thing but it
doesn't make any sense unless you have
decoded it we said anything
you feel like I'm about the dinosaur
side while the managers on the fault the
police this is what he does in the
morning he pours his coffee I've seen
him on this we're gonna do this every
morning with the wrong oh there was it
interesting detail there if you go back
that lady says you know him yeah
somebody did recognize the Bradbury meme
huh go back to where just a few seconds
yeah that's it I love this line mo has a
breakout line here
yeah he kind of steals the show yeah he
does Dennis pick it up on mo told you to
talk to me nicely fish
and and then he asked you know he wants
to clean it up it's not very gangster
but and they're like nah dude just we'll
take care of it you're good
so again I think the potential is there
but the regula was not fully realized no
masses back yeah our building is having
some contractions we're gonna slam them
with the regular grind on the building
they're literally on our wall yeah it's
scraping off the drywall yeah so try to
bear with us on that one there look at
try to look at the menu of Ross were
they in right now they're in a fast-food
restaurant the employee meanwhile is
being like what oh [ __ ] he's got a whole
language you get Bradbury has ascended
to the next level I want to say like he
is totally a sin so there and again
you'll see in his interest stories he
does that every morning where he goes he
takes the glass and he slams it on the
table and he goes raw rich he does this
daily yeah on the raw ritual ritual so
he wanted to go to Starbucks and see if
they had the rose for the rock didn't
have the Ross right he was gonna slam
him with it yeah that's what he did yeah
this is like we just tried to watch the
show and you've read the books yeah yeah
knowledge next up is it's been quite a
big meme that we for some reason kind of
so now would be a good time what
full-time extreme fire hazard data from
the deeper denser dimensions and so it
is an extreme biohazard to make
justifications for parasitism that's
true she sing there with their daughter
yes so we've got a mom and a daughter
staying home and raising children
we don't need children if you find
yourself pregnant there's so much you
said if you're pregnant get an abortion
like she just does not want babies
happening cool yeah so there's I mean
there's a lot to unpack here yeah you've
got the daughter who's channelling who
looks like autistic like she's
channeling the the Archangel Gabriel
sure of course sure that's true and so
it seems like they're on DMT or
something jungle and they're just like
here go to the next one man the daughter
just says that's true they have a
YouTube channel and we'd like a million
videos yeah dude it's almost like daily
posting hi friends it's good just get
the whole concept six 2016 in the lin
life and the Jamie body mind the
authorized Souls continued to be only
child episode 710 from the smaller sub
it just good and it's called cool and
some cool trees meaning larger and less
I love I love that and their minds
select these some trees are [ __ ]
now this it's kind of like gunfire well
I guess because a lot of people have
been talking about it so they added to
the description some frequently asked
questions yeah Daisy why does Jamie say
that's true yeah it's a little bit hard
for me to read phone do you want me to
read it
are these your opinions no we're
channeling angels and other godly
presence obviously why does Jamie say
that's true so often the answer in many
of these videos jamie has the
fact-checking job so as her mom's
talking [ __ ] she's talking to the
angels are going that's true but I've
never heard or once ate that's full
that's a good boy
I don't know if I dare read more is a
big block she says well let's see where
this goes
in many of these videos Jamie is the
fact checker not the primary Channel job
the fact checker is also focusing up
into the higher dimension and attempting
to discern what the highest vibration
voice is saying in any particular moment
right the primary Channel goofs wait
oops when the primary Channel goofs the
fact she just says something along the
lines of hold up that isn't what old
Otis often those segments are cut out of
the episode so we aren't misaligning
people who just jump in for a few
minutes and it's leading leading oh
that's probably misaligning too by the
time we could play editing an episode to
the best of our awareness everything
that's in it is true here's some
episodes 14 oh we're right we're only
seeing the true [ __ ] yeah Rost of the
raw right here are some episodes where
the jamie collective has the role of
primary channel
those are episodes 79928 hundred
episodes 919 to 9:20 and of course it
was oder it sees and twelve to ten she
didn't really give her much of a shot
that's only six out of a thousand of a
thousand yeah what are you doing with
your arms everyone has intuitive
channels but ever the channels are
resting upon is where our intuition
comes from because gravity is real
that's true intuitive channels fall down
sorry I need
the fact check that real fast intuitive
channels fall down when we don't hold
them up we are repeatedly lifting up our
intuitive channels so they get out of
the soup of confusion fear and untruth
that is rampant in human society right
that's true we do this so the god I'm
going that's true that is true you in it
yeah I'm gonna start doing this this is
my favorite disappointed here I'm sorry
and this one's for you is Jamie single
that's the dog that's not true no Jamie
is uh hold up that's what you say hold
up hold up relationship
are we on drugs no we live completely
drug-free Yeah right ladies so there you
have it man there were some other clips
of these I had a thousand of them there
was some good highlights though of them
going I do appreciate that they went to
the trouble of shaving their armpits
contracts committees to doing cuz I
would have been and with that three
normally videoed portions of today's
efforts begin but it is almost
contradictory because they're so big a
man and like yeah hippie that you think
they would Rock the arm pubes
mmm-hmm that's a good point that's true
that's true but those are so clean like
they waxed those before every episode
most of this world is actually believe
it or not I knew a woman that was like
kind of like this she spoke to angels
really if you said she spoke to angels
yeah you know in another lifetime
I was actually shooting a concert for
this whole group of people that were
like kind of spiritual guru me more like
this and we stayed at her house actually
for the time that because it was out of
town and so I'd like slept in the same
house as this woman for like two or
three nights and she was like very nice
and sweet but was like schizo she like
saw angels everywhere constantly and
they were like always telling her stuff
and she would like let us know what they
were saying
Wow yeah it was weird [ __ ] but was
she a maid ship it says this was like
the brats oh people by the way
the circle of people is brought on a
scale of one to ten as far as what
parents choose she was older she was
actually she was very pretty lady they
they are and that's the weird thing is
like in this like faith-healing thing
it's always very attractive middle-aged
women would you have sex with the lady
like that just to see oh I'm always more
inclined to listen to people when they
have like little Tony Robbins microphone
makes me think that they're saying
importance lawn chairs yeah those are
sixes those are action those are very
expensive really good must the mic
itself probably like seven eight hundred
bucks oh I like that
mmm hold on there there don't hold up
yeah the sound quality is really good
[Music]
what do you think no it's a terrible
toxic thing to do is have an abortion
yep
well maybe that did that influence her
belief right yeah I wonder if it's
either either it's like either at the
time she I mean by her logic she should
murder her daughter right yeah it's not
too late to have an abortion that's true
that is true
that's France true interesting stuff you
know one last thing is we never got to
talk about all these new him always you
did
[Music]
do we have another music yeah oh yeah
exact go ahead and hit us with CCC
corporate music the most emojis okay
this is the same energy for sure Yannick
these are the new emojis for 2019 200
and you're already new emojis that
basketball players [ __ ] no do we
really need all these they're so dark
it's almost like racists out dark they
minnesota's emojis like do you I've
never used the the people stuff all the
people clothes 70 future every shade
imaginable yeah oh yeah that's a lot you
know the yellow was like cool because it
kind of represented everybody at first
but now that they have like all these
different shades I feel like the yellows
racist because the only yellow left is
like Asian people and that's racist the
call is your person yellow probro became
cool that's what like old both probing
panes the hearing area mochi what the
[ __ ] they're really stretching them deaf
person woman and man mechanical arms
this is the inclusivity patent for sure
[Music]
oh cool flamingo it did one I did want a
flamingo
what is up a oyster that was super weird
sloth utter audit of your garlic baby
but a waffle Matt's tragical I also do
[Music]
made this Gila the emoji Council no this
is emoji pedia okay so kind of kind of
the other kind one of the authorities
there actually is an organization that
sanctions oh really yeah
sorry not sorry Oh brown heart white
heart there we go
in do temple sorry it'll bike get that
[ __ ] out ring planet not Saturn just
they don't want to yeah a copyright
strike from Saturday max adhesive
bandage like it hold it hold it hold it
that's the big one wait now the blood
drop you can pause the music yeah the
blood drop this is specifically supposed
to be menstrual yeah yeah that was the
big news from this emoji drop like I
showed you sneak that in there like the
diving mask going down on a girl during
your period there yeah I don't know when
they're coming out I do think there
should be a say man why I wanna say
these have been released I think I've
seen my list but maybe maybe I haven't
seen it 230 new ones yeah and that's
kind of suck honestly let's square
though I'm I'm using that otter I'm
gonna use the otter was cute I'll give
you I'll you know any of the 200 people
versions that
I'm gonna use that Sartre I'm gonna use
the darkest the darker the night one you
can only see the white in his eyes and
his teeth I feel like all of those suck
all those little people ones they do
there's no reason what do you I'm human
I'm human okay okay I am always caught
off when people use those and then they
match there's like skin tone and I'm
like come on yeah it catches me off
guard or when they'll send me one that
isn't theirs
mm-hm I mean I do like the old one right
I just use yellow gold like it's like
neutral right it's neutral exactly but
like you're not Asian so you shouldn't
be using the yellow on nobody like gold
you have to match your skin it's like
Simpsons white yeah you have to match
your skin tone and their and they're
gonna Morgan I've monitoring right emoji
is right and only single Simpsons face
right all right that's it well next I'm
up next
beautiful oh what a great presentation
good stuff and Dan is coming to the
plate he's got a whole slew I got a slew
I mean there's really just one big one
that I know where we're running a little
long here so I'll try blast through this
but so you want to talk about this a
while back I think I came into awareness
of it when Coachella was going on and
I'll explain why in a bit but first of
all have you guys heard that the the
influencer economy is crashing you heard
about this I saw that so stupid
so it's because this this girl with uh I
think like two million Instagram
followers Oh what's going on here and
refresh the site is not secure don't go
to pity to be 3.1 point she has 26
million for I wanted to the article and
she tried yeah I don't know why it's
blocking us you see like pops up when I
try and Cognito incognita
what's the hockey for it
yes you can get one mm-hmm
sorry about that those reasons here we
go yeah you all take me you don't take
me seriously all right Instagram
influencer with 2.6 million followers
struggles to sell 36 t-shirts now what
was the shirt she was trying to sell as
my initial question I think it should is
it the one at the top yeah where she's
sitting on yeah it's this one in the
bench it's just a black long-sleeved
t-shirt which you know it could just be
because your shirt sucks so man what
does it say no what is it how do you do
this just you just use your fingers CSI
stuff ooh it just looks like it's
initials I mean why would any I mean
what is this yeah I guess the point
being that you know she's got these
millions of people that ball around
social media but nobody actually gives a
[ __ ] or is engaged they turn it into
this whole thing where they says the
influencer bubble is about to burst I
don't think there's anything such as the
influencer bubble I think she was one
Instagram story she went and complained
gutted down no no it's all good so I
have a theory of why yeah these
influencers are doing so poorly it's
because they're just like in a lot of
industries and you know transportation
and manufacturing automation is taking
all the jobs and in this case it's pages
like this thank you for finally
acknowledged we got it we got little
Mikayla little Mikayla just about 36
shirts
well she you know I'll tell you in a
second she sold a lot more than 30 oh
really yeah she has less followers 1.6
million but you know it's a typical
Instagram page in most regards you know
this is this young girl I think she's
from LA and Dyke teat I saw at the bus
and she's nice she's 19 years old and
you know she's pretty and she's just
living that influence her life the only
weird thing is that she is not real she
is CGI fully she does not exist in the
real world and people think she's
totally real a study done by a full
screen actually they were researching
not just her but as you'll see there's a
number of these CGI influencers out
there hmm they did surveys of the
followers and found that a full 42
percent of people following her than God
she's a real person Wow which I find
incredible mostly because the weirdest
thing about all of this is the CGI
[ __ ] sucks yeah it's like ps3
graphics just so much I mean it's not
you know it's not like Sony
Entertainment it's just like some
marketing agency or whatever but it's
like legitimately so bad in some of
these what the [ __ ] and so yeah she had
she had some merch that she sold it's
called like Club 404 no very clever and
it's like an Internet online 404 yeah
which sold out and I mean they were it
was like some overpriced stuff
unfortunately because it sold out
doesn't show the price anymore but I did
some research and the socks were 30
bucks Wow for a 2-pack oh I guess for a
2-pack that's not too bad I think the
long sleeves I saw were being sold for
like 90 oh that's a lot I know they
weren't [ __ ] around and and it sold
out which you know who knows maybe they
didn't make that many so that it would
sell out but somebody was interested in
buying this you know what they do
sometimes dan the slick got people mmm
they'll they'll just say sold out so
it's not embarrassing right exactly
that's for that one Instagram lady
messed up because she went and
complained on his scam that no one was
buying her okay here's another one
that's probably the second most popular
only 135 she's way bigger than him yeah
no she is by far the biggest of all of
these because there's one number of
these and for whatever reason hers
really clicked and has this pretty and
when are we gonna get a sex tape between
these two coming so yeah this one which
by the way the most popular ones are all
by the same company it's one
organization so this this is the same
creators as Michaela as you'll probably
see because they they cross over all the
time you'll see him it they're all
friends mmm they have their living their
best lives together so yeah this is a
block code 22 his thing is he's got this
mask on at all times
I don't really know what's up with that
it's just kind of or if he's not wearing
it he's always covering his face it's a
budget cut is it here he is with another
one named Bermuda yeah which again like
this is like Sims graphic yes like I'm
not good at all
but you'll kind of see like if we go
back to Michaela in particular she's
under here that the people engaging with
these posts like they don't seem to
realize that they are I guess
so this is as someone's sex doll they
decided humanize on Instagram kay okay
so some people are starting to catch on
when I went to the to the older posts in
particular there were just like so many
comments of people like oh my god when
are you gonna be in New York next time I
want to come see you or blah blah blah
the way that I came to be aware of this
and this was [ __ ] weird as [ __ ] is
like I said I discovered it around
Coachella because on the official
Coachella stream they had her
interviewing one of the artists oh wow J
Balvin and he is interacting with her as
if she is a real person what's up it's
Michaela here with YouTube Music at
Coachella and I'm joined by Jay bobbin
Thank you Thank You mikela nice to meet
you finally
I'm gonna go for you everywhere but I
just had to see you let's just get right
into this I know you just look at like a
grapefruit yeah I think it's a person in
a body suit what do you think and have
in common
the person probably I mean a boy
you know like that you know I might eat
old it wants to
I was I was watching the stream just
normally and this just popped on and I
like did like a triple I'm like what is
wrong with her yeah like she looks so
weird and that's what kind of led me
down this rabbit hole here's another one
I think this is actually a different
company will wavy little wavy wavy this
one is like particular this one's like a
drawing yeah yeah interesting it's got
like the face tats it looks like a third
life character like yeah yeah look at
this one on the bottom left oh no Dan I
play third no I'm beyond that [ __ ] look
he's he's wearing supreme yeah that's
definitely just second life yeah maybe
Lil's and second life just to save some
money so yeah this one isn't as a goof
as much as I just find this really
[ __ ] weird and a little like this is
bad and like very obviously fake but
give it another 10 to 20 years and I
think the line between you know
celebrity celebrities that people are
into and follow you know influencers and
everything mmm it's like why would a
company bother you know spending
sponsorship money on a real person
that's you know she's 19 now but in two
years she'll be old news cuz she's 21
and you know lose her influence or
whatever if you is young forever yeah
yeah this is evergreen
you know Michaela I think launched three
or four years ago as a 19 year old girl
she's still a 19 year old girl and will
forever be the perfect age right damn
right that's right okay yeah certainly
interesting new brave new world kind of
thing yes exactly brave new world
yeah the the company behind this is
called broad broad broad and they're
based in LA they had like a little epic
hue on their site which was just like so
weird is where are you based we're in LA
is Michaela real as real as Rihanna
that's what they say I think what they
mean probably a thing in their minds I
think there's probably one girl that
wears the suit
mmm who has the boy who's like actually
makayley wrong about that but that's
possible I mean in most instances it's
just images so right sure a few years
ago they even put out a song oh no she's
a musician let's hear it
[Music]
Mikayla where you at you're not mine
[Music]
Dick's out what's the what's the view
count seven hundred sixty eight thousand
wait or is it just this it's just a
lyric video kind of thing which is like
why not make a video the laziest yeah
come on it's [ __ ] all CGI anyways so
they should just guys super realistic
right yeah exactly so yeah I don't know
I the main thing to me again is a I
thought it was weird but then it started
to make me real nervous for the future
humanity when I heard that almost half
the people that follow her think it's
real I mean that that is astounding to
me uh that is pretty wild well at first
when I saw her on the first time I saw
her on Instagram I did think she was
real but like there's just something
uncanny
yeah then eventually once you see it
then you then you like right that's all
that effect yeah but I think I don't
know I mean I'm looking forward to VR
porn with like hyper realistic you could
like Llorona the way long and you just
strap on like a machine deer penis and
like you just lay out do that now right
don't you have the gear you've got the
oculus I haven't actually tried VR but
it seems like a lot of hubbub just did
you took a lot of effort yeah just yeah
one out that's my thing kind of the
antithesis like the point of
masturbating at least for a guy is to be
like alright we got to get this poison
out alright let's let's get this over
with get the poison out get the poison
out just get it out I have on yeah it's
like you've got to brush your teeth you
got to do it's not something you want to
do it's like exactly you want you after
but you know it's not about breakfast so
I don't enjoy masturbating it's just
something I have to do
okay do you know what I mean Zack knows
what I mean I do thank you thanks always
got my back you Ian never has my back so
this this surprised me Shane Dawson was
like on the [ __ ] immediately apparently
this is from two years ago in one of his
videos he did a short phone interview
Michaela can see she's come a long way
in the last two years because this is
like yeah this is like place they should
to grab there I say Dan that she's aged
I guess maybe did make her look a little
bit older this this this is definitely
more like I don't know 16 15 16 year old
looking yeah but you know they can just
kind of change your looks with the with
the trends what's in whatever moment so
yeah she's shout out to Shane did we get
an interview or anything interesting
here uh no it's not really interesting
to be honest listen to it I mean he's
talking to a person who's pretending to
be a CGI influencer it's what's it is a
point like what's this thing that what's
the conspiracy it wasn't so much that it
was conspiracy I I have a feeling I mean
this is just my speculation I don't know
this but I have a feeling they they paid
you think that's a good I think it's
that's the conspiracy within a
conspiracy because cuz why would he talk
to her and you know this was two years
ago I'm sure she had a much smaller
following this whole thing is a big
effort of a marketing agency you know in
turn so they're they're looking to make
this go viral so get it on Shane
Dawson's channel why not there you have
it folks
little Michaela yeah so that's it for a
little Michaela and her CGI friends but
yeah
don't don't follow these accounts no my
guess is is my point in all this don't
don't give this attention this is not
good it's not it's not I don't think
this is good for us these robots are
gonna take you out my job will ever be
in Jefferies two robots I mean probably
they'll be honest
no I mean hopefully I'll be one of the
last to go but can you imagine like a
hilarious robot this was like AI
algorithmically funny
Albert well I mean they're already
making these robots that can
algorithmically write music and do
things that are music seems more
formulaic you know yes no I mean yes it
does seem more formulaic but I question
if it really is any more formulaic than
doing comedy you know what I mean like
there's certainly an x-factor to a good
musician that's improve a
improvisational right but I like to
think of myself as as someone that's
untouchable and untouchable talented
beyond even musicians or anyone else
I couldn't possibly duplicate it an
algorithm right now I think you have a
really strong point there for sure
I have your back now you don't always
leave me in the trenches I I feel like
made certain joke styles probably not
but if you took all of the Late Show
data oh yeah
for every monologue from the last like
30 years from all shows I feel like you
could make like a joke but I feel yeah
that's a good point there could be as
there is a place by an algorithm for and
I think it would be better to be honest
I'd watch I watched a little chin ekwa
but I think that's an interesting
observation in and I think it's because
it's so formulaic yeah and the topics
and though their delivery yeah but I I
think that's interesting I would be
interested to see how that played out
yeah someone get on that see if you can
do it well I've I've seen studies that
or articles that that claim that all
that kind of stuff is coming like people
are working on you know automating jobs
that you wouldn't expect you know
everybody thinks an automation
self-driving cars and that kind of stuff
but even creative jobs could be in
jeopardy in the future you know just the
robot can do it cheaper faster all that
kind of stuff and I mean when half your
audience is paying so little attention
anyways that they don't even realize
that it's fake sure you know I don't
really after quality anyway so you know
I've been watching I've been following
that deep fake we
since we're talking about that last time
they've already gotten way better yeah
and I'm not even talking about porn like
never feel like people are over the porn
thing I've been seeing like goofs just
goofs we're yeah or I saw one today
where they put Kanye's face on Mike
Tyson for example right I saw that and
like it's gotten so good yeah it's
unbelievable Segura it's incredible this
guy just called the fake inning I think
it's called yeah yeah is it not it's not
even pornographic anymore it's just for
the goofs actually Tom Segura has a
weird like dude there's no difference
Tom's is so seamless he looks a lot like
art though that's true it's not going
that far from one in the other
oh you but the expressions and
everything who's who is pays put on - no
Tom Segura with this guy the thickening
must have like a [ __ ] insane computer
should maybe stop this here stop stop
stop
deep fake don't fight me bro as post
Malone yeah this one is crazy it's just
unbelievable the expressions the IRA
eyebrows the mouth unbeliev that looks
kind of tight it looks like magma hand
tats he asked me if he should do it I
don't yeah maybe it's because it needed
to go further then to be done that last
one but Jim I feel like I choose this
isn't quite so seamless like you can
tell there's something weird
yeah no I mean it's good though you'll
see it's or it is improved a lot and
these are just people just messing
around on their computers but Samsung is
like deep in this right now right they
showed something they have that just
from one photo yeah they can fake in
your ass that's and they're trying to
have that be able to be on a phone on
anyway are born yeah that's what
Samsung's working towards Samsung's
Korean South Korean right yes so yeah
that makes sense so that way you just
take a photo and you can have sex with
anyone right yeah there you go
sick legit so that's it basically I'm
very good that conclude your report uh
yeah I mean very good is it and thank
you so we've got a step up to the plate
and here let me say you up here so me up
from here how are we doing timewise we
got all the time in the world baby deal
everything good you got two hour mark
just about I see you don't have you oh
you got the you got the dollars in the
Arnold right yeah well then I wasn't
sure about the the tree yes let's do all
of them they're fantastic we can't say
no well powered through there no memes
left fine so Arnold Schwarzenegger the
man the myth the legend you know other
car everybody loves Arnold our former
governor the Governator so he got he got
a little publicity the other day because
he was
he was in Africa on this liked meeting
fans event in South Africa he's taking
pictures of someone and then this
happens some guy just Sprint's up and
just tropics the Terminator he failed
that what that that robot from the past
is [ __ ] that's a really shitty cyborg
they sent to assassinate oh yeah there's
another angle here that Arnold tweeted
out oh I love the Arnold shared it
himself
yeah what a legend well Arnold was like
not even fail yeah he's like barely
moved what a freaking legend and he's
like in his late sick maybe even older
really maybe yeah I think he's almost 70
yeah really he's built like a tree stump
dude yeah that's incredible that guy I
think they would have broke my back yeah
I mean it's his entire body weight
flying through the air double he's 71 71
that motherfucker's built like a goddamn
I like tree stump I'm gonna stay with
that tree trunk tree tree trunk yeah I
think you made a coma after that he was
like oh yeah you know I thought someone
just bumped into me ha and the guy he
screams I need a Lamborghini is that
right yeah he says help me I need a lamb
burger yeah why
[Music]
it's an interesting approach to acquire
that but now he has a Lamborghini yes
and he exactly congratulations them man
I'm impressed with the Arnold dude yeah
no he's he's doing all right
just imagine one just imagine that is
the sequel to Terminator and like they
just really build a she'll you robot and
that's the whole movie you see the
trailer for the Newton Terminator know
any good you're thinking of Rambo aren't
you know there's a way oh that was
making Rambo
some people go making sure there's a new
Rambo trailer there is a new Rambo blood
what's the context of the new
terminators it look good you know I went
in balled up totally skeptical that's
pulled up it looks it looks kind of dope
I like Terminator I like this series I'm
Mike I'm a fan we're using the original
Sarah Connor back she said oh I saw
right I saw an image but I haven't seen
the trailer that's cool this is it's
like the actual terminator to Cass I'm
just not sure how many oh my one that
was good oh no I think I've heard that
this is a direct sequel to Terminator 2
they're like just the rest which yeah I
was like it's probably for the best
let's see here we got claim for yeah I
love when I got claim for showing a
[ __ ] trailer is that the point I
don't care go ahead
it's a nightmare I haven't you know it's
real when a schedule and a piano I was
about to say and a piano and it came in
[Music]
and then here comes this weird African
do to drop kicks Arnold how many movies
have there been in this lost dragging 60
or 70 this is probably the seven footer
so I only saw the first one oh damn
wait a second or a robot what was that
oh that's not Sarah Connor oh okay
I'm assuming that's the new Terminator
sent oh no as Arnold Arnold's got to be
in it right yes thank God look at her
dude that's pretty badass I like your
old ass a bazooka
what's up haters the bazookas come like
a 90s action trope I haven't seen in a
while
that's very true
never seen one like you before almost
human who Sarah Connor actually don't
remember I am human oh [ __ ] because I
was her
oh man he's aged why did the robot age I
was a very good question he's just a
robot living out in the woods a gen I
think this movie's gonna suck I mean
probably
I think this movie's gonna be an
absolute suck fest and it's not James
Cameron directing because he's still too
busy making avatar - for the last two
decades but Linda Hamilton's Linda
Hamilton there is gonna be awesome if
avatar 2 was a total flop at the box
office
I want that be amazing hope it is so bad
would that be so cool so you're probably
right that it's gonna suck first of all
the evil terminator singing in the end
there I mean what is this that was him
but Wyatt and it was him okay so this
next one while stumbling around YouTube
sometimes I'll just keep clicking
related videos and then see what happens
and I end up and that weird part of
YouTube and that's where I found this
phenomenon known as reborn dolls so
anymore reborn previously from theirs
that's a whole thing where there's a
whole theory but yeah well it's regular
dolls that you'd buy some of them kind
of cheap and then these artists will
take them or these interesting so they
are designers will take them and then
completely reconstruct them okay and
completely redo them so and the main
market for this people buy them on Etsy
and on eBay because it's a lot of just
just fan-created
not faint artists created entrepreneurs
but here's like the Etsy page holy [ __ ]
for these dolls nope nope so tell me Dan
who like what's none of these are real
these are incredible yeah and so who's
buying these like I mean what's the
point what who what what purpose are
these serving so it seems to vary
because some pricey to it yeah
that's expensive some people uh actually
they're just doll collectors and this is
like next level they just like
collecting dolls
can you imagine stepping into a house
like that yeah and then there are other
people who are using it as like grieving
tools see that's not I figured that was
really tragic and probably not a good
idea either
yeah well that's yeah it's kind of got a
these different avenues and I was
reading the empty nest people - yeah
some people just this one shop I was
like 2000 reviews reborn baby oh that's
a good price I mean sorry but that means
that many people bought it she might be
selling other stuff and some people I
watched documentary on it on YouTube
about it and some people will take
pictures of their kids and maybe when
their kids grow up and they'll go and
like have it Duplo my goodness I would
not want my marriage to do that a
picture is work and then you know then
they can go use all their old baby
clothes and stuff like that and you know
some p.m. some people were saying they
did it because they just weren't ready
to be a parent they didn't think that
they could handle it there so they were
like this is much easier for me sure it
is yeah they're like I'm sure that's a
good towel and get ready to be a parent
yeah I wrote one of the quotes down from
one of these people in this documentary
where she said oh wow where I haven't
got children I still do have that female
instinct in me I can't do the commitment
to kids it's so fussy if I could pick a
child off the shelf I would one that's
quiet and well-behaved unfortunately
reality isn't really like that she
bought the next best thing
yeah she just bought one but yeah it is
kind of when you $600 plus actually so I
looked at the most expensive like a
newborn like right
yeah dude that actually I do admire the
artistry yeah
oh they blurred the fake penis go back
they blurred the fake penis with
Stardust yeah well right went on there
so yeah that I looked at the most
expensive one ever sold I went and it
was it's better be good see better be a
damn fine baby eBay apparently this
seller is very well renowned for their
dolls so this was so more $2,000
what oh my god what's so amazing about
this baby
well it's a Romy baby first of all it's
like it's all about the label I mean I
guess the details probably are so I mean
well yeah and I think with this person
they got nails done up and [ __ ] they
gotta like mani I think a lot of them a
lot of the people that sell them like I
said they're repurposed dolls I think
this one may have been all there was no
scratch that added on to the value but
yeah it's it's it's pretty crazy and the
uh yeah that woman she's like the
Picasso of these dolls
yes ideas Romy you can come on here and
oh my gob why is his baby dead what kind
of dead oh my goodness gracious what the
imagine I mean what is weird yeah I
wonder if this lady planned on getting
into this or she just fell into it you
know what I mean that's a good question
yeah start making hyper-realistic
silicone babies she just found a niche
she's like these people are [ __ ]
crazy but they pay L they be really good
I mean 23 grand for one oh my gosh
Tiffany every finding tau and now pan I
tell you if I snood coming up on
something like that and hands are like a
real baby
I would 180 out of that house
immediately
this is literally start of a horror film
and the cow looks slowly she grabs for
them well apparently like I was reading
how they're made and they'll they'll put
weights in the head so you have to like
support I like the real thing and
they'll match that it's just the
cleaning and the doing the hair seeing
the end result and then pushing a nice
pan so yeah we'll go take my marks and
stuff and so people who see her think
she has a real baby yeah it's gonna die
right dude that's [ __ ] weird I didn't
think that they actually went out in
public with them yeah because that's
kind of like that's a weird weird twist
actually it's the psychology of it it's
like then it's about like being seen and
perceived as a parent and yeah this was
important part of this is actually how
she'll she goes and sets she makes him
and she goes in sells him like at the
grocery store she push no she's she's
there to sell a baby
yeah because so it's like viral
marketing for somebody coming they want
a baby
no for real that's the best way you can
market this
oh mama look at that I want to see the
people that I like [ __ ] what that that
is a weird twist yeah and so I was
digging around this just on YouTube I
mean the front room is now the nursery
where babies are engineered to customers
specifications you can have worming
pouches said that the babies actually
warm making out breathe was made the
joke that you would throw it in the
microwave to make it hide they accounted
for it already you can have you can
customize them so they breathe you can
open noses open ears you strive to reach
the ultimate and realism that's what
it's all about you're trying to create a
baby either moving wait that was a real
baby man seems like there's a decent
market for it is because there was like
a lot doesn't like a super boutique
thing first I was looking at I found the
very interesting one on YouTube that was
[Music]
this person makes them and this was this
was a little overboard I think being
very gentle pinch and pull up
you don't not and not here by the is it
just a latex glove just a giant condom
Jack Link's box in the background link
baby that no it arrived promo we are
going to gently pull apart the rest of
the way for your baby to be born the
baby oh that's not a very well okay now
that baby needs resuscitation of
something that's ready look that's a
little blue role playing that you've got
okay so there before umbilical cord
you've gotta take she's gonna save them
for themselves and it says I want to do
it exactly like my things it's gonna
inject it into her face like Sandra
Bullock super cute okay
so cute Wow like a corpse yeah it's kind
of berries the people said yes or
silently amazing all these videos I've
noticed have crazy views oh five million
whoa whoa
five million yo I didn't realize was a
thing yeah that has been around okay
they started started around in the 90s
just doll collectors wanted more
realistic dolls and then as it went on
and they started to pull it off then
this whole other element came in where
people were kind of using it as like you
know a placeholder for real human babies
and that's where it gets quite a
disturbing
last little part here I've thought
apparently this has happened a couple
times now with these things where a
police officer broke into a car on a hot
day to save with
why don't you leave that in your car I
mean what do you think officer even
called an ambulance and tried CPR I
don't blame the guy yeah of course
a good that's a dumb thing to do course
happen horse model warhorse it was that
a war some Ainsley's mom got the dolls
to help her cope after her son died
that's the way you're gonna kill your
freaking your your fake baby's not gonna
make it either leaving them in a hot car
no if I would still break it they
probably have it in a car seat too and
everything
Oh God yeah so write it with you I've
read that I'm in it right that's
happened multiple times Wow put it in
the trunk or some that is [ __ ] trunk
wild chest baby yeah but anyways that's
the that's the little crash course on
the world of we thank you for that Thank
You Zach and then just the last I want
Drake yeah it's too good okay we'll be
the family so the NBA playoffs started
last night the final series I'm sure
we're all big sports here yeah it's
between the it's between the New York
dinos in the yeah Golden State I love
when they get it in the hoop yeah oh
dude the yeah when the thing that put
the ball goes in the home runs a
basketball right no but anyways there's
a kind of this drama playing out because
well it's the Toronto Raptors versus the
Golden State Warriors and the Raptors
have been they've never been the final
this is the first time good for them and
their main well Drake is from Toronto
and he's like a die-hard fan he owns
some he has some investment in the team
and they made him their official like
team ambassador mm-hmm so because of
that Drake gets he gets access to the
court like for all the games lore game I
mean he's on the floor he's he's there
he's like standing next to the coach
every game and so this has started to
become a problem and other teams have
started to get kind of pissed off about
it here was from one of the last games
this was last week he's right there he
was ready to squad he's ready to shoot
he is ready to roll NBA yeah
that's cool so he's just that snip right
there and the cameras not helping cuz
they keep showing it yeah he's already
cut to him and send it to the players
and he has a thing look like the he's
taunts players he thought [ __ ] yeah no
it's happened before the big one day
sight is Spike Lee right I mean when
you're but he's stealing the show yeah
it's definitely he's like playing it up
look at him standing he Mays dominating
though and then this was the other one
that had like a bunch of sports fans up
stats look at him running around the
sidelines like we're I mean he's me
running around the Cyber Dragon oh and
he that's the coach of the team he's
comfortable out there
yeah it needs to respect the game yeah
that's been the big things go back to
the beginning of that clip and I want
you guys to watch him just running
around courtside like yeah like a color
like really you see him I mean that's
pretty ridiculous he's the cheerleader
[Applause]
you've got to respect the other team you
know yeah and then the other rub really
gets me they ask this one I thought was
kind of funny they asked the the head
coach of the other team about that whole
thing and like his Drake too involved so
this was the other coach just kind of
saying no this isn't cool but these
clips of Drake are just so funny
participant in the game of coach I'm
sorry a player or a coach that you know
has access to the court so I I don't
know how much he's on the court it
sounds like you guys are saying always
it's kind of a bad precedent you don't
you know like what's to stop other
celebrities from running around you know
[Laughter]
I mean he's having fun out there though
I like I don't have that much fun in my
life ever
yeah he's pumped he's loving it he had a
line to be animated like that at a
sports game like that's what makes it
fun but you can't go on the [ __ ]
court yeah do it
yeah he's money problem that's why when
he said the talking [ __ ] I'm like that's
talk [ __ ] all you want like that's part
of the fun of being in a sports game
that's a Nike supreme nutty and this was
after there just won that game when he
was massaging the coach just all these
people it's about these people right
here it's about these people it's about
the city we a listen listen we have the
best player we have the best fans and a
hole in a hole NBA in a whole world look
around look around you look at this we
created this this didn't exist before we
are here look around at the square I
promise you right now we did this
doesn't matter what anybody says they
can say it's disrespectful they can say
is this and that now everybody's within
everybody's within the rules everybody's
doing their thing all yards proud and
passionate we are like a college sports
scene the Toronto Raptors are polished
more see my promise was that man loved
Toronto I love this team and we're going
to the NBA all of us it's funny how they
go interview him after the game he's
stealing the limelight yeah yeah yeah
so the NBA actually after this when had
a meeting with the
afters they had to go talk to him and be
like guys Drake's
antics hurt you got a good train oh man
just put him in a mascot suit and then
I'll be right yeah yeah the Raptor dude
yeah
well that's because he's his brand is
like the Owls yeah and he does all the
jerseys and Bradbury's you'll see an owl
on the Jersey that's all Drake right but
so they warned him they told him to
chill out and then the first game of the
final was last night and let me guess he
did not chill out at all so first there
was this is hilarious yeah this was from
his acid Graham oh he posted this so
he's flaunting yeah he's posting this
one
now his Steph Curry on the Raptors or
not Steph Curry's on Golden State so
he's talking [ __ ] and he's wearing this
Jersey with another different player
from Toronto whose last name is curry
from like years ago so he's it's no I
heard it's it's his dad
Oh his dad was so angry leaders yeah
okay who's wearing his dad's Jersey
talking [ __ ] to him so this is an
elaborate Lloyd
[Music]
anything that he's got something in his
hair and he's yo he put in music but an
intense action me his caption Steph
Curry hair limp for sale on my eBay
right now user named Ramon shouldn't
wear 23 so oh my goodness that's real
beef he's hurting real beef isn't he
kind of let me see that clip again I
don't think Steven I don't think Steph
is happy about what's going on there no
it seems like he's like [ __ ] I'll
[ __ ] either stop call me shenanigans
[Music]
yeah oh they are great as a Steph Curry
tattoo oh my goodness oh they're goofing
around but it looks best
they do look but the other motion might
be running high yeah and the other
player that he's trolling here there's a
draymond who's also on the team they had
a an exchange at the end of the game
[Applause]
this was right after Toronto beat Golden
State I could see Drake walking around
up left flat bin
so the he's friends with this guy well
that's all Toronto but then here's Steph
and then this other guy draymond and
Drake are arguing and then he actually
yelled you're trash after they and so
then someone asked that player about it
right after it's incredible that Drake
has made himself the center of attention
he's an NBA player yeah yeah so like
where players have to like acknowledge
him and talk about this yeah right by
that their exit yeah just wanted you to
talk a little bit about that postgame
scuffle between you and Drake you got a
question about basketball it wasn't
really a scuffle because I didn't hit
him and he didn't hit me or I didn't
push him and he didn't push me we talked
we barked a little bit but I wouldn't
necessarily consider that a scuffle not
really what I personally will considers
this guy good for him then click stop
trying to play bad gonna [ __ ] deal
with this hooligan on the side yeah he's
right so yeah of all the sports
commentators and stuff have been like
Drake's gotta cool it this is not this
is amazing invested in it financially so
yeah clearly he's got motive right
that's true he's promoting his team yeah
you know being able to cause that's what
Toronto wanted because that's what it
like a global ambassador is supposed to
do okay you know they pick high-profile
people I think that's yeah they were
probably stoked to get Drake is there I
think that's what like Jack Nicholson is
for the Lakers Oh for real think so yeah
you know it's funny they go they pull
the raptors into the NBA office in the
like yo tricks got a chill and they go
back to directed like hype it up though
but raptors have never won the finals
ever they've never even been there
Golden State's one like seven so I get
why he's pumped but you know it's just
kind of funny you think they got a shot
to win it this year
uh well they beat them last night I'm
not super I don't know it with it but
okay I guess I'd like them to win just
because they've never won the story's
game yeah and I bet trick will take full
credit for them winning last week
actually the daughter of the owner of
the Bucks the team that they beat to get
in the final the daughter sat on the
upside into the court with a big push a
t-shirt on oh wow like and that district
came out a year ago though right
a year ago like two days ago oh I love
it yeah it's fantastic yeah I think it's
pretty funny so I'm looking for to watch
the gas I know exactly where to mark
Drake highlights from you in because I'm
not gonna watch them but I trust that
you need a Drake cam just all just see
what he's doing separate stream is
pretty much only a couple memes were
left behind to be honest I'll tell you
what they were there's only two and
we'll get him Nick but just so you guys
know chase made an awful tweet and Josh
the bad kisser we're the only two memes
LaVon but we'll get to them so it's
Friday my dudes okay
the blessed Friday God's Friday Jesus's
Friday Jesus died on a Friday in fact
and he was also risen on a Friday fact
check that I think heroes know heroes on
on Easter I think it was a Friday they
the calendar was different back then
cuz they he's oh he sees right beef
right Sunday's was not easy because he
was alive so it wouldn't be BC but I
mean it was uh it was uh he was kind of
like older well it starts after his
death I think the ad is after death no I
mean I know it's not good let's just go
down yeah no let's go with so happy
Friday God's dad used his day remember
that Jesus was died and risen on Friday
for a reason God was singing on Friday
as the busted end greatest day so I hope
you guys have a busted in grade Friday
and thank you for so much for joining us
being here with us thank you to Ian
whose birthday it is everybody wishing a
happy birthday but
the Sharkey's gift card on your well dan
can thank you Dan for joining us today
the producer of great stories for you be
Europe's ela who's probably gonna be
giving birth before our next episode oh
[ __ ] that's right
give it up see ya or bring it in it come
again I mean what come on
shredder than I waited so patiently for
us and Zach go ahead Zach was really
good on the sounds today Zak who's on it
thank you ball
thank you give it up his ass back
ringing Sarah it was all thing and today
thanks for joining us and getting on the
switcher so the boys could get in here
we appreciate you we love we love that
you're here you can go ahead and switch
it to yourself we can share we can I
control that normally there's back there
and of course go ahead and switch it to
the person watching would that be
awesome face game and thank you alright
that's it we'll see you next week
I mean he'll is probably gonna give
birth but well I'm gonna check I don't
know when cuz if it's on the Friday I'm
not gonna able to come obviously but I
do I'm gonna come in and I'm like it's
my updates and probably share some
pictures and stuff and just talk about
it I'll take a video of her of the baby
coming out so look forward to that
Ian looks like he's what seeing a ghost
that's that why did I'm thinking I'm
seeing the ghost of Sharky's yeah that
is dramatic alright guys thanks for
watching see you next time
ha
[Music]